[Music]
all right breaking just tonight ranking
member of the House Intelligence
Committee congressman Devin newness of
California has notified the Attorney
General he is submitting eight criminal
referrals alleging serious misconduct
during the Trump Russia probe
he joins us now congressman what can you
tell us about this you are you say in
your letter which I have in front of me
that it is serious when will we know who
and what for well we don't know if
you'll ever know who but I can tell you
that if you follow what the Russia gate
Russia hoax closely if I gave you seven
guesses you'd probably be able to get
the five people that we have referred so
there's five direct referrals based on
lying
obstruction of a congressional
investigation and leaking we have a
global leaks referral which involves
just a few reporters but could involve
multiple people I don't think it's that
many people because I think they
probably only have a few sources within
these agencies and then you have
conspiracy referrals ones based on the
manipulation of intelligence the second
one is based on FISA abuse and other
matters and so that's where we stand
those are the eight referrals at this
point we're prepared to brief the
Attorney General I'm looking forward to
taking with a former US Attorney that's
now in Congress John Ratcliffe who
serves on the Intelligence Committee and
on the House Intelligence and Judiciary
Committee so he's going to go with me
to brief the Attorney General when
appropriate let me ask you we do know
from the newness and the graphs of
Graham memos for example let's so stay
on FISA that the bulk of the FISA
application that pages 10 to 12 17 to 34
and the last one in particular I've been
told is important but the bulk of that
information came from Hillary Clinton's
bought and paid for unverified
uncorroborated not even supported by its
author to Russian dossier that is a
fraud before the court court is it not
sir conspiracy even well Sean let's just
let me let me make it as clear as I
possibly can
okay and now that thank God we have an
attorney general who calls spine for
what it is in Lake top 2015 early 2016
spine began on the Trump campaign that
information leaked that led to what they
consider to be legal spine that began
that they've acknowledged that they'd
started doing in at the end of July you
all you just had Carter page on they
consider that all legal spine
they then leaked that information right
shortly after the election all through
the spring that was leaking out why to
create a narrative that Donald Trump
shouldn't been president that he's a
Russian asset etc etc so spine and
leaking then you have the culmination of
the ultimate spying where you have the
FBI director spying on the president
taking notes illegally leaking those
notes of classified information why so
they could appoint a special counsel to
spy on an Acting President again
so there's a lot of spine and a lot of
leaking and I think that's as clear as I
can put it I won't push it any further I
understand and I would ask you often you
obviously had more information than I I
would say is there anything that I've
said tonight that's wrong and you often
would say no and I'd ask you the same
question the next question am i over the
target because I I want to be right and
I have a lot of sources that I'm putting
pieces of a puzzle together and
sometimes people cannot give me
information I want to ask you
specifically about the Hillary Clinton
investigation now it's thanks to
congressman Collins we now have the
closed-door testimony of a lot of people
Nelly Bruce or Peter struck and and Lisa
Paige and now James Baker the general
counsel who said the following described
Clinton's behavior as it relates to the
the server where she had top-secret
classified information on it as alarming
and appalling and argued that he thought
that she should be charged and page and
struck said both of them they had no
control over that investigation and
although struck himself did the
interview allowed two other people in
the interview
is unheard of and was writing her
exoneration in May before interviewing
her in July and exonerating her three
days later Comey did that part do you
believe that that investigation into
Hillary was a rigged investigation and
should it begin anew
look I don't know that because we didn't
look at all that information but I will
say that I don't know how destroying a
server that should have been there in
the first place is not obstructing
justice another important point you
talking about with without classified
information
we still have still are waiting on
transcripts with with with classified
information on it but I want to remind
the viewers we still have transcripts
from our investigation that are sitting
over at the DNI that still have not been
Declassified and those need to come out
also that will give a lot more
transparency to I think everything else
that's going along with the transcripts
that you're seeing now and the last
interview I had with the president he
said he would be releasing the FISA
applications the gang of eight the 302
materials when Americans see that will
they be shocked than if so on a scale of
one to ten how shocked well look I what
I've said and I'll say it again if you
thought using dirt from a campaign as
bad you'll think this is equally as bad
if you didn't think there's bad then you
won't care and now look if what have
happened to the other side they would
have really cared great point all right
congressman thank you so much for being
with us
we'll follow those closely